[Music]
hi welcome to three scary games on
October 22nd 1999 Daniel Lennard and his
friend Heather Merrick went missing
while on a camping expedition
despite ground an aerial search attempts
no trace of Daniel or Heather were ever
found
October 22nd 1999 who is cracking sticks
over there oh my
press T or d-pad to toggle the
flashlight Oh weird
Slendy van Slenderman we we're don't
like that mmm
would that don't look good the style of
this is really cool I got to admit but
also what the hell is happening here
okay yeah I'm just gonna go wandering
into the woods I'm just gonna go
wandering into the woods
hello should I actually go help her
should um should I not I never know why
I'm asked no thank you no thank you
nothing
all right my nose is running with fear
Heather was that your name I can't
remember what's my name Who am I I don't
like any of us I don't like anything
about this I like you see exactly none
of this I want to go home as that is why
what is it what about what am I looking
at
[Music]
yeah he's a place I don't want to be
I've just discovered there's a place I
shouldn't be boom hit it hate hate hate
hate hate it hate this hate it I hate
this okay what's gonna happen when I go
up to the illuminated with a candlelit
gravestone with the paper seem to be
flapping on the back ass of it I mean
nothing good that's clear nothing good
will happen that's dead obvious P hey
I'm sorry
hello mm-hmm
hate hate everything I hate all things
all things of this that I hate there's
another pay poor if I supposed to follow
the trail trying to act like an idiot
break some of the attention bauble Babu
is so young I am a fool is what that
means
nope I have a fool are bonito I am a
fool not I have a fool that was a person
I don't know if I'm going the right way
I don't know if there is I guess I'm
going the right way
ow hush help you help me what I didn't
know I could run you know I'm gonna save
that I save it cuz I'm cool and calm and
collected and I ain't scared of no
ghosts I ain't afraid of no ghosts was I
supposed to follow the voice I feel like
maybe I was supposed to follow the voice
I don't know I want to follow the voice
oh god I want to follow the voice I want
to follow the voice I don't like
whatever that is it's very phallic and I
am NOT about that big weird rock big
weird rock big weird rock big weird rock
big weird penis Rock Oh big weird
glowing penis Rock put my ear up again
oh I hear that I'm coming I'll be right
there
Heather Heather Heather
oh the light the light
[Laughter]
[Music]
no no no no no no oh boy oh boy
ah awesome here I go it's a face that
doors on Easter Island head oh no no no
the doggy door got boarded up Oh
leave me alone
Steve in my corner now I'm just gonna
stand in my corner oh there's a door the
geometry of this locale makes me think
that this dorm
I feel like I would have oh oh hi oh hi
oh you've got friends good
I know you say oh oh yourself huh what
happened what did I just see my exhale I
know my cell
oh cool good good
you da bazzill all right cool great love
the ambience hmm what is this button do
nothing are you guys out there any on
sale there you are
hee hoo hoo ha ha ho I'm blind I can see
it's the big penis rock I can't move hey
I'm back
my flashlight doesn't work seems to be a
lot of blood and writing oh I have a
body I gotta say this is an extremely
well-designed experiments to self craft
rabbit fur fabulous clothes : have you
guys seen my sploosh clamor I'm missing
it I stopped that with my body all right
cool good
Oh front door wide open I guess I can
just leave then Oh onlooking do it again
are you sure about that
are you sure door you sure let me
double-check oh come on all right I'll
go upstairs
la dee dee Lana there ya a lot of deal
on today oh good well there that goes
good thing I got this glue uh stairs
gonna be fun
hi Oh namaste I didn't find that rock I
can tell you that much I did not find
that rock that was an important mission
that you needed me to accomplish I did
not find that rock I bought he blocked
it again
thought I heard other footsteps there
for a moment
oh that's always good that's even better
a new zoo penis so you'll never say oh
hello my turn my turn I wanna ride on
the pentagram in vain his if mom said
it's my turn on the pentagram hi ru oh
oh that can't be good either
sure I'm breathing here to hoovy hello
he be who V's hefty heavily
[Music]
where's my compass all we believe overly
oh whoa what are you running for huffing
the little ol me no stay good see well
see around t run been due here on the
band fun man someone took the time to
make all of this I'll tell you what well
now see I don't want to go in the
basement but it seemed mm my mental
fortitude caused that light to stay on
I'm just that amazing hi oh you did
indeed there wasn't even a door up there
how did you do that
oh no oh no I've been gone I've been
gone I've been had mine spider-man
you're not spot
whoa my turn
oh nice
triangle and you ruined it oh no wait
you're about to ruin me oh I see that's
not good that's - what they called the
don't be Goods self-id you're too
twitchy far too jiggly for my thesis oh
that's a lot of jiggles okay that was
such a polished experience that was
fantastic obviously inspired by the
Blair Witch Project but that had so much
polished to it I loved it didn't do a
lot of things too out of the box for an
indie horror game but even so it had
this style and it had the dread and it
had the who the mystery to it I love
that that was great really nice stuff
okay whoa
moving on alright so this one is not a
traditional horror game but I think
that's almost good because it's a game
that takes place under the ocean where
you are a simple egg trying to not die
even this opening screen is scary I hate
the ocean the oceans place with death
terrible hi I'm an egg oh oh where am i
what is surrounding me and why is it
pulsating I don't like it
hold left and move ah tap right - - and
smack whoa Wow
Oh Oh interesting Oh those eggs my
eating eggs ha whoa
I eat that guy up yump haha you can't
survive little brother ha ha
what Frick
oh hi whoo I don't like it I don't think
I ain't eat you oh no no Loulou know
these little the caviar they've got it
AHA oh ouch you die you die oh I'm dead
damn it okay that's horrifying I hate it
and everything about this see it's not
like a traditional horror game but it's
just oh yeah yeah get out of here yeah
yeah I'm gonna what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna hit that against the rocks enough
until it dies and then I'm gonna eat it
then I'm gonna eat it unless I can't eat
it Oh wha get up on those rocks you're
good ah maybe I can't kill it maybe I
maybe now I'm big enough that I can get
through this
oh I can't yeah okay okay okay we're
getting get away from me get away from
me get away from me okay hey hey come
here you
oh that ain't good ah get away from me
ah get away get away get away get away
get away
weird tube thing Oh weird everything
about it horrifying yeah how we how we
are we oh yeah we no no no no no no
don't suck on me is that a boob oh my
god I don't suck on me all this I'm all
sack of a bulbous sack of eyeballs don't
suck me oh god you're never gonna go
area oh you're just my always now aren't
you the music is too nice and pretty
[Music]
oh I'm being a big baby nothing
nothing makes me hate biology more than
seeing the actual ocean and this is just
it yeah that's awful okay Oh what are
these things
evolution is terrible evolution made a
horrible mistake it's set at the bottom
oh I'm spinning up a storm my spinning
maniac oh no no no I'm just a bag of
eyeballs you don't want to touch me
I'm very dirty him full of germs not
worth it trouble oh it's an indicator of
my next growth stage I am out of here
wha oh oh I've got a face oh yeah you
you you you afraid now oh I'm sorry are
you afraid now yeah oh are you are you
afraid of what I'm about to do to you oh
I'm sorry are you fearful of the fact
that I'm going to eat what am I gonna
what am i I don't know what I am okay I
don't think I'm just doing this to get
some revenge okay alright can I go in
the hole
[Laughter]
oh god you got stuck douche oh god oh
god you're huge
you're so big what is that I'll get you
yeah oh I thought that was a weak point
it is isn't it it's a weak point I'm
gonna get you you're gonna get gone oh I
think it knows oh no it definitely knows
oh it definitely knows oh please what
did I just break what am i where am i
what is this
what's with the riddles I hate it I hate
everything
the ocean is awful it shouldn't exist
and it's thirst brother you die now
brother young brother this is horrible
this is everything about is horrible
this is horrible horrible ah brother you
shan't evolve anymore brother brother I
don't know what weird kind of room we're
in but it's the worst hi alright hi oh
man you were far along too bad lovable
this is all biology is just everything
eating each other always and forever
never-ending cycle of eating each other
forever is the thing at the bottom of
the little face down there any
indication of what I'm going to become
because if it is I don't want it I just
don't want it oh no no please not like
this you don't want to what happened to
you what what what what what what what
what why was that thing like half Chomp
oh so confused okay oh please don't
please don't please don't don't suck me
oh boy oh god no please not like this
I'm big now you can't get me what
happened to this thing
what chomped you that's my question what
the hell if you can be chomped what am I
gonna do oh boy that was a mistake why
did I do that I was like charging at it
like I've got you now wait why is my
symbol of blood douche why am i oh boy
that's not what I was hoping for what
what chomped you what the hell chomped
you Oh God
charge charge ahh
[Music]
whoa-ha-ha
horas yeah dude I could have played that
for hours
legitimately I could have played that
for hours it was such a fascinating
concept
I loved the bizarreness of it I loved
that the mechanic was so simple but it
was so satisfying because I played games
like fishy-fishy
where that's the whole concept but that
it makes for a fun game but to have
actual plot behind it cycle of never
ending eating itself and I guess that's
what happened to the big purple dude is
he ended up eating his own tail for some
reason whoever made this the developer
there oh my god expand this into a full
game so all the see is number one a
great name for a game number two this as
a concept is so fantastic like you could
go so far with this make something out
of this can't believe it so good thank
you
all right moving on alright so this last
one is called harmful play the tape
all right Dan McGrath let's see what's
going on here oh hi kind of perspective
is this
that's not good that thumping from the
trunk or something oh this ain't good
why is my face so pixelated oh there we
go hello
[Music]
this guy's like straight out of the
earliest schools of vlogging to set your
camera somewhere just let it run
what does move what is moving what am I
seeing something behind that fence by
that tree on the left side what am I
looking at
oh wait oh my god I'm an idiot
Here I am again on my own I could have I
thought you know all right cool all
right where am I going oh there I am
going great I think I'm about to find
out what's harmful mmm man this this
video feed is real disorienting mmm
don't like it
my vision is no bueno hello one of my um
what am i doing in these woods in 1997
what could a man okay I was about to say
what good man such as myself be doing
out in these woods but apparently it's
camping apparently the answer to my
question is camp Eng mysterious tent
it's bigger on the inside than it is on
the outside I'm camping and filming
myself camping I'm Michael Scott trying
to film a survival series because that's
what I do
hi you guys don't mind if I set up camp
right by your house and
something tells me they ain't never
going to mind again hi hey neighbor
how you doin buddies howls friends okay
cool
mind if I steal your sorry it was a joke
it was a joke it was a joke joke big
joke oh where am I
what why is it 143 in the morning why is
it 1997 I have many questions I guess
I'm done here God all I needed to know
answered all my questions you practicing
rocky stabby big upcoming stab and match
oh thank goodness I have oh wow oh wow
oh my oh my Who am I who mmm knife drill
real war P uh a knife don't want to be
static hey how you doing all free and
nice nips y'all go go now I'll go I'll
leave
gonna go Oh
[Music]
602 m made it by five nights at freddys
rules I have survived I win
Oh up
um
ah so what what I'm gathering from this
is I when in luhan's
set up camp near someone's house snuck
into the house and went under the
floorboards and then I was the murderer
who killed everybody and I was just
filming myself that's the only
explanation I can get to it because how
would that tape either way that it was
anyway I must have waited in the house
for them to come home or why would I do
that all right
okay all right anyway that was three
scary games thank you everybody so much
for watching if you want to play these
they're linked in the description that
swallow the C game was really cool the
first game was really cool - I can't
remember the name of the first game this
is pretty cool but it was more of a
cerebral game or of a philosophical
adventure but still cool so thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to check out more scary games that
I have done there are so many linked in
the description check them out huge
playlists and suggested videos down
there if you want to see more scary
games in the future let me know what
scary games to play in the comments and
subscribe and ring the bell to know when
the spooks will be coming no I won't do
it but thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye oh yeah I was hit
my mic are they
[Music]